i'm gonna ask something and uh you know
so i watched joey's video where
he interviewed you and i watched a ton
of videos that you were in on youtube
on youtube
i can't say that because earlier i was
like yeah i was i was doing my research
to connor
about about about your career and he
just burst out laughing
you know how it is right i know so i i
wanted to ask because it must be
i don't know this is what i want to know
on joey's video all the comments
on every single video that you're in are
always the same it's like oh opens up
chrome tab to search yeah
it's like oh how did you like not you
know look at your breasts or whatever
like does that get annoying like when
you're just want to collaborate on like
a podcast like this person kind of you
know feel sorry for joey too because
no no no no no no i also invited him to
join my
radio show you know when we pause
and we can we share like we retreat yeah
there's at least one com at least yeah
yeah one comment saying
oh like is actually okay with it like oh
maybe they're gonna have a threesome
right
like they just think that you just like
cannot stop having sex yeah
it was a job not a lifestyle
yeah yeah exactly and b i was very
retired even at that time yeah yeah
i am now but but even if you were still
working in it this assumption that you
just you just i gotta make a porno i've
gotta [ __ ] something and film it like
it's so strange i felt i felt bad for
you like yeah i didn't really care
because
it's just my comments right whatever but
like because like the whole point of my
interview with you
was to get to know you as a person right
and obviously it's a you know
of course it's inevitable that we're
going to cross that right
right because we're going to talk about
it in your career right
but like yeah like obviously it wasn't
every comment it was a lot of comments
but i saw a lot of comments as well who
are like oh you know like i i totally
saw a different light in her like you
know yeah she's actually a really nice
person and like that that was my whole
aim right but of course
the internet is always going to be the
engineer so i was just really
yeah but like i don't know i would be
really annoyed if i was you
if i if i went on to an interview of
some person or anybody no i just
appreciate this
you guys so much for bringing me out
here in spite of all those like future
we want to bring this up to call out the
[ __ ] comments now because what's
going to happen is right someone's going
to
immediately type this comment before
they watch the video they get 30 minutes
in they're like oh [ __ ] i got to delete
that
and if you don't you're you're just
gonna be casted as a clown in the
conversation
right at least be creative you know
that's all i want yeah yeah yeah
we don't we don't need the same five
millionth incognito mode comment
yeah we're gonna see on every video be a
man don't use incognito
keep that [ __ ] in your history the
apartment in the other dominance